[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a diario de copas el espacio
de france 24 donde analizamos la
actualidad de la copa américa y la
eurocopa a continuación a continuación
nuestros titulares
europa vibra españa y suiza se enfrentan
en un duelo inédito por los cuartos de
final de la euro 2020 la roja llega al
partido motivada al derrotar a croacia
pero con cautela porque se medirán a un
conjunto que viene de eliminar a la
actual campeona del mundo tenemos
informe desde madrid
alta expectativa italia y bélgica dos
equipos que marchan invictos y con
averaje perfecto en el torneo se miden
por un boleto a semifinales será la
cuarta vez que se enfrenten en una
eurocopa y los azzurri no han perdido
ante los 'diablos rojos'
tendremos análisis y reacciones
[Música]
un nuevo torneo ocho equipos de
sudamérica se mantienen en carrera
dentro de la copa américa los duelos
perú paraguay y brasil-chile abre en los
cuartos de final del torneo de
selecciones más antiguo del mundo
evaluamos el momento de cada uno de los
equipos
como en cada una de nuestras emisiones
contamos con la presencia de sara castro
directora del diario colombiano
bienvenidas hará como siempre un gusto
estar con ustedes
sara vamos a revisar rápidamente todo lo
que tiene que ver con la actualidad de
la eurocopa en este caso españa y suiza
se enfrentan en un duelo inédito dentro
de los cuartos de final de la presente
edición de la copa en este caso los
españoles acceden a la instancia luego
de dejar en el camino a croacia y por
otro lado enfrentarán a una suiza que
llega con la motivación de haber
superado en octavos de final a la
selección de francia
sara son dos equipos que comenzaron el
torneo de una manera dudosa quizás más
en el caso de españa- pero que llegan a
este partido particularmente con gran
momento sin duda españa es el favorito
aunque no es un equipo 100% fiable lo
que sí vimos ante croacia es que
alcanzaron su máximo nivel en juego y
confianza eso es fundamental
luís enrique tiene una idea muy clara
busquets es fundamental ahí pero me
parece muy interesante analizar un poco
sus declaraciones en cuanto a los
defectos defensivos que tiene el equipo
y él dice que más que preocuparle lo que
hacen sin la pelota le preocupa lo que
hacen con la pelota y ahí está muy
marcada su línea de acción yo creo que
el partido de mañana va a ser muy
interesante porque vemos el fútbol suizo
tiene la influencia de muchos otros
estilos de juego uno por ubicación
geográfica y también por el origen de
sus jugadores y usted henrique decía
porque se analizaba sobre el desgaste
físico que supone estas prórrogas y él
decía que si uno está bien de la cabeza
abuela es decir ese vínculo emocional y
físico que hay en este tipo de partidos
él está muy convencido la baja más
fuerte para suiza va a ser la de chaca
que seguramente se suplirá de manera
colectiva entonces vamos a ver un
partido súper interesante es lo que ha
hablado suiza a lo largo de todos estos
días pero para conocer el ambiente que
existe en españa en torno a este partido
veamos el siguiente reporte que nos trae
nuestra corresponsal en madrid laura
españa vuelve a los cuartos de final de
la eurocopa por primera vez desde el
2012 el viernes se enfrentará a suiza
aquí en madrid todos los españoles están
esperando con ganas ver ese partido que
se jugará en el estadio ruso de san
petersburgo los aficionados están
deseando ver un partido tan emocionante
como el del lunes en los octavos de
final contra croacia vivieron un
thriller en un partido que acabó ganando
la roja cinco contra tres ahora todos
los periódicos españoles hablan del
choque contra suiza el diario deportivo
marca advierte ojo suiza no es un
enemigo tan asequible recuerda que el
país está eufórico tras su victoria
contra francia actual campeona del mundo
y que su estado de ánimo es óptimo este
partido es el primer encuentro en la
historia de la eurocopa entre suiza y
españa pero de los 22 encuentros españa
siempre ha ganado todos los partidos
excepto el último en el mundial de 2010
y sobre este partido habló en el día de
ayer unai simón que era el segundo
arquero de la selección española
escuchemos lo que digo
y bueno yo siempre he dicho que siempre
nos han dicho los más veteranos del
equipo que estas competiciones estos
partidos los ganan los equipos si no las
elecciones no sé cómo irá la verdad al
final
da igual que haya una afición que esté
igual te puede pitar o lo que sea que
sea el rival nosotros hacemos nuestro
fútbol parecía el día de croacia que
había más croatas en el campo y yo sólo
escuchaba españoles también habló el
seleccionador de suiza
vladimir pétkovic escuchen
te amo tiene este somos optimistas y
haremos todo lo posible por ganar este
partido y pasar a la siguiente ronda
todo respeto bears adversario tenemos el
mayor respeto por españa juega un gran
fútbol y ha marcado 10 goles en los dos
últimos partidos el reto de partida se
ha corrido mucho más que su rival
esfuerzo tanto tanto pie así que
ciertamente tenemos mucho respeto sin
embargo tanto despertó más tenemos si
queremos creer en nuestro sueño y
queremos ir más lejos a todo el vamos a
andar adelante otro duelo de cuartos de
final estará protagonizado por las
selecciones de italia y bélgica las
cuales llegan a este partido a
disfrutarse en el allianz arena de
múnich ambos equipos están invictos
luego de haber ganado todos sus
compromisos y entre ellos tres de la
fase de grupos
sara pareciera que este partido llega en
un mal momento por las dos selecciones
que una de ellas se vaya en cuartos
pareciera muy poco en el torneo
absolutamente es un partido para una
final si uno mira las estadísticas la
última
que bélgica le ganó a italia por una
eurocopa fue en 1972 pero estamos
hablando de una generación totalmente
diferente y muy bien trabajada por
roberto martínez sin duda en la ausencia
la probable ausencia tanto de hazard
como de uruguay es lo que marca un poco
las decisiones que se van a tomar en el
partido seguramente estarán mertens y
carrasco ahí sufriendo intentando suplir
esa zona partido interesante porque
bélgica ha mostrado que es un equipo que
sabe leer muy bien los momentos de
partido y ha cambiado la estrategia y la
táctica durante el partido lo vimos en
el choque de octavos y seguramente lo
veremos mañana de italia el equipo mejor
trabajado con una idea que tiene
variantes desde la salida del juego y
también desde la manera como hacen daño
en el fondo
en el fondo un duelo además muy conocido
al de lukaku y donnarumma que se han
enfrentado muchas veces en el derbi de
milán así que un partido muy interesante
con muchos talentos y sin duda lo que se
le plantea hoy a manchin es que los
goles casi siempre le han llegado desde
el banco y es si mantiene ese once que
ha sido la estructura o si de pronto le
da por ejemplo la oportunidad a piscina
y no en móviles en la zona del ataque
hay una seria duda en cuanto a bélgica
por lass
lecciones que presentan en este momento
kevin de bruyne y eden hazard cuanto
podría cambiar
bélgica con o sin estos dos jugadores el
primer partido de esta eurocopa ya tuvo
esas ausencias y lo suplió muy bien este
bélgica de liga tiene jugadores muy
importantes en diferentes posiciones no
tiene esas figuras rutilantes como viene
a ser de bruijn pero si es un equipo que
colectivamente y por lo que hemos venido
hablando tiene una huella de trabajo muy
larga y eso hace que esas
transformaciones tanto tácticas como
estratégicas durante los partidos se le
den muy fácil
carrasco es un jugador muy importante a
carrasco es un jugador desequilibrante
que si bien va por fuera también puede
ir por dentro y empezar desde lo
colectivo
nadie suple a un jugador como de bruijn
que sin duda es uno de los mejores
mediocampistas y no el mejor del mundo
pero creo que tiene muchas soluciones
desde lo táctico y también desde los
nombres en roberto martínez para suplir
esas ausencias con este análisis pasamos
a la copa américa porque a partir de
este viernes comienzan los cuartos de
final con dos partidos a primera hora
perú
enfrentando a la selección de paraguay
mientras que en el cierre de las
jornadas se estarán midiendo las
elecciones de chile y brasil pero
escuchemos qué dicen los protagonistas
de este partido
el hecho de jugar un torneo donde nos
toca enfrentar al local siempre es una
dificultad brasil ha dado muestra hacer
además de eso el equipo posible
posiblemente más en forma y eso
lógicamente genera una dificultad pero
también es una oportunidad sea así lo
tenemos que tomar tenemos que hacer el
mejor partido de todos los que hemos
jugado hasta ahora eso siempre es
posible está lo que el rival te deja no
te deje hacer bueno vamos a trabajar
para intentar minimizar sus virtudes e
intentar explorar sus defectos si eso es
posible quizás esté muy partido pero
creo que con equipo creo que es un
equipo muy habilidoso por eso ganó dos
ediciones seguidas de la copa américa
inseguro esta escuadra sabe jugar este
tipo de partidos no importa el momento
que están pasando
siendo séptimos en las eliminatorias al
mundial y sólo ganaron un partido eso no
te dice mucho con central lips o mensch
ist cuando te enfrentas a la selección
brasileña todos quieren ganar todos se
preparan bien
chile recibe la buena nueva de
incorporar a alexis sánchez que
presentaba una molestia física pero que
debe hacer para poder vencer a este
brasil que luce imbatible para mi chile
es uno de los equipos más competitivos
de esta copa américa si alguien le puede
hacer partido a brasil es chile no sólo
recupera alexis sánchez que todavía está
en duda si juega detrás de bretón y de
vargas sino también recupera pulgar que
es el eje del equipo es el que quita y
sale con el balón muy muy bien
chile tiene la experiencia y la
jerarquía de ya haber ganado por eso
siempre se va a hacer referencia a eso y
también jugadores de mucha clase y de
calidad qué pasa con brasil que no le
hemos visto el tope en esta en esta copa
américa ha ganado casi todo el último el
partido lo empató pero no sabemos cuál
es el nivel real ya para este partido ti
te tendrá que alinear lo que es su
equipo titular y seguramente veremos
también una intensidad de juego muy
diferente es un partido interesantísimo
insisto que para mí chile puede hacerle
un muy buen partido a brasil y sobre
todo con los antecedentes que a partir
de la idea de ti te lean
algunos equipos como por ejemplo
colombia que lo puso en dificultades
cuando le cerró los espacios por el
medio y también le llenó el ancho del
campo entonces creo que chile llega con
herramientas también para enfrentar a un
brasil de manera clara y creo que
anticipó un partido interesante luego
vamos a ver si cuando brasil acelere le
da oportunidad al otro equipo de pensar
el otro partido es entre las selecciones
de perú y paraguay que estarán buscando
un boleto a la semifinal estamos
hablando de dos equipos que llegan muy
muy parejos y para este encuentro alguno
tiene que marcar la diferencia de esta
manera llegamos al final de diario de
copas por el día de hoy continúen con
más de la programación de france 24 y
france 24 puntocom